bonjour amadou sadio barry merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur arte france au
programme des discussions prévues
jusqu'à demain donc climat santé ou
encore numérique qu'est ce qu'il faut
attendre de cette quatrième édition
écoutez il faut d'abord se féliciter de
l'organisation de cette édition
dans la mesure où nous sommes dans un
contexte de pandémie qui a lourdement
éprouvé le monde comme tel sur le plan
économique sur le plan politique et sur
le plan de la coopération internationale
donc je pense que il ya eu ici à travers
ce forum la conscience d'un destin
commun qui est en train de se traduire
dans une forme de responsabilité
collective qui ils ont lucas même depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
tarde à se concrétiser une
responsabilité collective ou même global
qui pourrait prendre en charge les défis
aujourd'hui liés aux économies à
l'organisation politique de notre monde
pour qu'ensemble comme collectivité
humaine nous prenons en charge notre
destin collectif donc là dessus il faut
qu'on a quand même salué sur le plan en
tout cas des principes ce forum la
question reste à savoir pour les pays
pauvres par exemple où les états sont
défaillants je parle ici de la majorité
c'est en afrique même en asie du sud est
ou encore à l'amérique latine est-ce que
la distribution de vaccins par exemple
pourrait régler l'incapacité des
institutions dans ces pays là à répondre
aux besoins développement et surtout à
la production scientifique parce qu'il
faut lui dire ce n'est pas des
scientifiques qui manque à l'afrique par
exemple simplement un problème de
financement de la recherche et d'une
incapacité de se réapproprier tout là
les capacités innovantes dont font
preuve par exemple les africains de
leurs chercheurs vous parlez de
l'africain parmi les trente chefs d'état
présents à paris pour ce pauvre homme 12
viennent du continent africain justement
après le g20 et la coop 26s que emmanuel
macron essaie de faire du pied aux
leaders africains une quatrième édition
de ce forum de paris pour la paix on le
rappelle qui est axé sur la réduction
des fractures mondiale
écoutez il est clair que le président
m'a cran son passage à l'elysée quand
même reste marqué par une volonté de
reconduire si vous voulez une politique
étrangère de la france en tout cas de la
réaffirmée de manière très forte avec
des engagements sur le plan symbolique
mais aussi sur le plan institutionnel m
à travers l'union européenne pensons
encore au sahel malgré tout la
difficulté par exemple lire l'opération
barkan donc il a quand même une volonté
du président macro de redéfinir la
politique étrangère de la france pour
sortir un peu des critiques qui consiste
à dire que la puissance européenne ou en
tout cas la france en particulier
s'affaiblit depuis 45 sur ce point là on
peut quand même dire que la diplomatie
française elle est en train de
développer une forme de soft power en
tout cas de pouvoir non pas simplement
sur la dimension militaire mais aussi
sur la dimension symbolique la dimension
institutionnelle capable de relancer la
france comme une puissance qui demeure
encore malgré les critiques par ailleurs
en ce qui concerne l'afrique justement
la question ici n'est pas de savoir est
ce qu'il faudrait privilégier un devoir
au niveau international et que les
démocraties occidentales les pays riches
doivent aider l'afrique je pense que sur
le plan moral la question ne se pose
même pas c'est le cas par contre c'est
de savoir jusqu'où cette responsabilité
globale même ou en tout cas cette
instance habilitée française sous sa
forme actuelle peut contribuer à
justement à ce que les états africains
puissent relever les défis du
développement économique sain pas le cas
parce qu'il n'y a pas de relation de
causalité entre l'aide internationale et
son actualisation à l'intérieur de
l'afrique c'est là toute la difficulté
parce que lorsqu'on fait un bilan
critique de l'aide internationale toute
la justice au niveau global on voit
quand même que les états africains les
institutions africaines ne sont pas
capables de se réapproprier l'aide et
donc de la traduire dans des véritables
politiques de développement et surtout
dans les politiques capables de sortir
l'afrique de la dette donc ça aussi
c'est une réalité qu'il faut dire ici on
parle d'un forum pour la paix avec de
nombreux représentants africains en
afrique on ne peut pas dire que la paix
règne vraiment partout les exemples
guinée avec un coup d'état récent le
mali avec de coup d'état le soudan
également ou encore l'ethiopie et le
conflit aux tigres et en quoi ce forum
peut-il aider à trouver des solutions
pacifiques dans ces pays en proie à
l'instabilité
écoutez vous venez de lui dire c'est le
grand paradoxe semaine a fait se met
pour la paix parce que évidemment qu'il
ya des enjeux une fois encore qu'ils
sont qui sont de l'ordre international
qui sont des enjeux qui touchent
l'ensemble de la planète les enjeux
sanitaires par exemple la question des
crises économiques la question de la
dette en afrique évidemment que les
démocraties libérales les pays riches et
les grandes puissances vives sont plus
confrontés aux externalités souvent de
ce qui se passe en afrique ça c'est vrai
en témoigne par exemple la la question
de la crise migratoire et est maintenant
ce qu'il faudrait voir c'est justement
nous sommes dans ce forum la sur fond
quand même de guerre pensons à
l'ethiopie la guerre du petit gris on
voit aussi au sahel vous avez cité des
pays ou dans la grande majorité des
régions d'afrique le continent est
fragilisée par où des tensions liées aux
questions électorales ou des guerres
liées aux problématiques territoriales
pensons aussi aux cas ici de du mali au
nord du mali en particulier donc une
fois encore c'est toute la l'ambiguïté
de l'aide internationale parce que nous
avons souvenez une contradiction entre
ce qui se passe au niveau international
et la manière dont les états sont
organisées sur le plan interne et
surtout la façon dont la politique
étrangère des pays riches structure tout
le rapport avec le gouvernement en
afrique c'est là qu'il faut aussi
essayer de mener la réflexion parce que
on voit que les états africains dans
leur grande majorité sont des états
faillis c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont pas
capables d'organiser par exemple de
pouvoirs publics de manière à ce qu'ils
répondent aux défis de développement les
zetas ont failli dans le sens au sud où
ils ne sont pas capables d'assurer leurs
prérogatives en matière de sécurité on
voit qu'au sahel lecteurs quelles que
soient les critiques qu'on adresse à la
france tenue n'était l'opération barkan
je pense que beaucoup d'états du sahel
se seraient déjà si vous voulez tombait
sous la main des djihadistes donc
là-dessus encore la véritable question
aujourd'hui c'est ce que la france peut
prendre le leadership d'une véritable
réflexion sur l'aide internationale
capable non plus de distribuer de
l'argent mais de réfléchir sur les
conditions aux internes susceptible de
faire des institutions politiques en
afrique des institutions capables hui
là-dessus l'europe où l'occident a de la
responsabilité mais il faut être clair
si à l'afrique aux africains aux acteurs
politiques africains de pouvoir se poser
la question de savoir qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent pour eux-mêmes dans un monde
aussi fragile et en panne de
responsabilité collective c'est là où il
faut distinguer pour terminer la
responsabilité au niveau international
et la responsabilité au niveau national
il me semble que depuis soixante les
acteurs politiques en afrique tarder à
prendre la mesure de la responsabilité
internationale capable de sortir
l'afrique des violences liées surtout à
l'organisation des élections merci
amadou sadio barry d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
auteur et professeur de philosophie au
cégep de saint-hyacinthe à québec c'est
également chercheur en éthique des
relations internationales